a hundred dollars a month invested from
age 25 to age 65 is one million one
hundred seventy six thousand dollars and
the idiot's response is
but a million dollars isn't going to be
worth that much in 40 years
let me tell you what it's worth more
than you're going to have
because you're such a that you
look at that example and you go well a
million dollars ain't gonna be worth
anything so what am I going to do
nothing
and when you do nothing with your
investing you know what you have nothing
because you know what the number one
indicator if you're having money and
wealth that retirement is that you put
some freaking money in the account
instead you go well it's not going to be
worth anything
and you sit around I mean what kind of
what kind of moronic response is that
loser response